And here's my solution.
First I compute the mean using the mean function.
Assign it to a new variable that I make up called mu.
So this is now inside the variance; I now know the mean.
Here's how I construct my new lists--my ndata lists.
I first set it to the empty lists.
Then I go through every index in the original data structure.
So len(data) as we know gives me the number of elements.
Range constructs a list of indices from zero to one minus that.
Then I go through it sequentially,
and that allows me to index the i'th item in my data structure.
Now I take the i'th item.
I subtract the mean.
This is a very short notation for squaring it.
I could've just done the same times itself.
But this is my new i'th element that I append into my ndata set.
So we're doing this with a for loop.
I get a parallel data set called ndata
that is data minus the mean, squared.
Now I compute the mean of that new ndata and return it; that's my variance.
It turns out there's an even more elegant version to do this in Python.
It requires a good amount of programming skills
that are probably way beyond most beginners' programming skills.
Here is how it goes:
You can do this in two lines.
You can compute the mean, as we've done before
with our function mean that we programmed ourselves.
And here is the tricky part.
We're now going to compute the mean of a new list.
We can construct this new list in a single line--that's the key thing here.
The way we construct it is we go through all the data items
for x in the data
and we construct a new list out of it
where the math for constructing the new list is x minus mu to the square.
So this loops through all the data items, applies this equation to each data item,
constructs the new lists, passes these lists on to the mean function,
and returns the correct value.
So this is one of the compact ways of programming the variance.